We have made it to our final Cake of the Day.
♪ Cake of the Day ♪
It's the Sam's Club cheesecake.
And trivia, the first cheesecake was made
in ancient Greece, way back in 776 BC.
Which stands for it before cheesecake, right?
That it should.
The athletes at the first ever Olympics ate cheesecake
for energy and vigor.
Huh, that's funny.
After I eat this, I just want to be
on the couch and passed out.
I haven't had the Sam's Club before.
Get ready to have your doors blown off, Ross.
She does not lie about cheesecake. That is so good.
Speaking of old classics that stand the test of time...
Chess, a game that's over 1,500 years old
is 2020's biggest hit because NBC News reports
that chess boards are selling out everywhere.
Sales are up, get this number, 87%.
Wow.
After the success of Netflix's "The Queen's Gambit".
And the fact that they have so many people,
obviously at home, this is the perfect potent cocktail.
Yeah, it's always been too complicated for me.
I'm gonna just stick to checkers. Right?
I love Checkers. I'll play checkers with you.
Done.
I can handle checkers. Chess, not so much.
Oh, look what I got everyone, it's my whistle,
which means it's time for sports, sports.
(whistle blowing)
(everyone cheering)
ESPN reports the Olympics just got a brand new sport
and it's not what you think.
Break dancing is now an Olympic sport.
It'll premiere at the Summer Olympics in Paris.
I mean, it still means I have no shot at a gold medal ever,
unless they, put like "Steel Magnolia" quoting as a sport.
(everyone laughing)
Another dope thing, what would you do, Ross,
if you found something worth thousands of dollars
in your brand new home?
I'd do the right thing...
(both laughing)
I'd like to think I would do the right thing
and call the previous owner and say,
"Hey, you left something behind."
Well, that is exactly the decision
that our next guests made.
Wow.
James and Clarrisa Munford.
Good for them.
CNN.com reported that the couple stumbled
upon $25,000 worth of coins hidden in their closet.
Well now, I didn't know it was that much, Drew.
Well, let's ask James and Clarrisa
why they're such good people.
James and Clarissa, hello welcome to the show.
Hi.
How do you know how to do the right thing?
How do you do it? Teach us all.
I think it was instilled in us
'cause of our faith in God,
And our parents and grandparents, they taught us well.
Were you tempted for one second to keep it?
Just one second, James?
I wasn't.
Clarrisa?
Clarrisa pleads the fifth on this one.
Maybe one second.
One second. I think that's fair.
I think that's totally fair.
And then, when you told the previous owners,
"Oh, we found 25 grand worth of stuff here,"
what did they say?
He was very surprised.
He forgot that they even left them down in the drawer
where I found them.
So he was just very gracious and very happy
that we notified him of the coins.
I just figured they was a family heirloom.
They need to be returned back to him.
I mean, you could have used the money,
I heard you have repairs on your house.
What projects are you working on right now?
Mostly flooring right now,
because the house had a lot of carpet,
and I have allergies.
The downstairs is done,
and now they're going to be starting upstairs.
Gosh, you guys are such good people.
I feel like we all need to step up our game
in honor of James and Clarrisa.
And I just, I don't believe that good deeds go unseen,
and kindness is so contagious.
And so is karma.
Yes.
And 84 Lumber is the nation's largest
privately held, building materials supplier
owned by Maggie Hardy Knox.
When they heard about your story, and wanted to honor you,
so they're going to give you $25,000.
(everyone screaming)
(audience applauding)
Oh my gosh.
Are you serious?
Are you serious, really?
(audience applauding)
Amazing.
Oh my gosh. That is so such a (indistinct)
You're gonna make me cry. That is amazing.
You know what? That really is karma.
And sometimes I don't feel like I see it quick enough.
And, this is reaffirming my, hope and faith in life
that good things happen to good people.
And 84 Lumber has a passion for giving back
to the communities it serves.
In 2020 alone, this company
made over a million dollars in charitable donations.
Great.
(audience applauding)
Thank you for being the example of true integrity.
Thank you.
Thank you for having us.
Thank you for everything. This is definitely a blessing.
Thank you 84 Lumber. We are so thankful and appreciative.
James and Clarrisa, thanks for being you.
(upbeat music)